(melancholy music)
I tried running too.
It doesn't work.
It always follows.
All due respect, that's your life, not mine.
I'm not so sure about that.
What do you want from me lady?
Hey, watch your tone new girl.
You know how they always say it goes back to the original?
Here's the original.
I want your help because you're wrong,
this is your life now, which means that whoever this is,
is gonna keep coming for you.
So?
So I want you
to help us kill him.
You want me to help you
and the host of a morning show commit murder?
Correct?
Yeah.
(audience cheer and clap)
Hey, if you can't beat 'em, join 'em!
That's Courtney Cox and Neve Campbell in the new "Scream".
And we are here along with David Arquette.
(audience cheer and clap)
All right, this is what we've got, it's the final thought.
(drum roll)
(audience cheer and clap)
All right, I'm gonna ask each one of you quick,
rapid fire questions.
David, worst habit during the movie.
Drinking has been the worst habit,
(indistinct) thank goodness.
Neve, what was your worst habit during the movie?
We were staying at the DoubleTree Hotel
and they had cookies on the pillowcase every day,
and I ate those cookies every single day.
(audience laughs)
Courtney, what was your worst habit during the movie?
I wonder if I smoked then?
I probably did, yeah.
Did I?
Yeah.
Smoking cigarettes.
David, what is the scariest thing about you?
Well, I beat myself up.
I'm just very critical of myself
and that's the toughest thing.
Nev what's the scariest thing about you?
I'm Canadian, there's not a whole lot scary about us,
Yeah, I don't know honestly.
I'm passing it to you.
I think mine would be my critical voice.
Maybe not in the same way,
dealing with, as I get older
and all the other things you do to criticize yourself
as opposed to just accept.
That would probably be the scariest, the voice.
David, have you ever seen a ghost in real life?
I don't know, I feel the energy sometimes,
but I don't think I've seen a ghost in real life.
Neve?
There was a house that I owned,
the very first house I owned that someone passed away in
and I was not the only person to have experiences
in that house.
Courtney, have you ever seen a ghost in real life?
I haven't seen a ghost,
but I did live in a house that was believed to be haunted.
I entered the door one day and there was a UPS guy
or a FedEx person there, and they said,
"Do you know that your house is haunted?"
And I go, "Well, I've heard that, but why?"
He goes, "Because there's someone standing behind you."
(Drew gasps)
That's a good, scary one.
That's a good one.
That's a really good.
(audience laugh)
Okay, last question.
How did this movie change you David?
We had a daughter out of it
and she's the greatest thing in my life.
And yeah, so that really is the most impactful thing
that's ever happened to me
in this business.
Yeah.
Neve, how did this movie change you?
I mean, this movie gave me everything.
It was a springboard, I think for all of us.
I mean, its success really helped pave the way
for all of us in our careers,
and my life would be very, very different without "Scream".
Yeah, I hear you on that.
Courtney, how did this movie change you?
Well, besides the obvious,
I will not go to the bathroom in a movie theater
or just about any sports arena.
It doesn't matter.
I always sit underneath and prefer just not to go.
I will not go into a parking lot by myself.
And if I do, my heart is racing
and I'm constantly looking.
Okay, I'm so honored to be a part of this journey
with you guys.
And I congratulate you
with all of my heart
(audience cheer and clap)
for 25 years on "Scream".
Thank you.
Also, everyone in our studio audience is going to go home
with this 4K ultra HD DVD
(audience cheer and clap)
because it's out for the very first time like this.
Thank you to Paramount Home Entertainment.
(audience cheer and clap)
"Scream" 2022 premiers this Friday, January 14th.
And we'll be right back.
I love you guys.
(upbeat music)